あのずっと
2年前くらいから授業をやってて
この季節になるとくるんですよねその世界大会
乳業の世界一を決める大会があってその各店舗で予選が行われて言ってで勝ち上がった
人が高日本一のまずとりあえず世界体験でには日本一にならなきゃいけないので日本一
になるために今各お店とかでね3月から4月ぐらいまでには予選が行われ
れて言って僕今回その大会に出たんですけども
いつも決勝までは行きました1回戦に1回戦準決決勝ってやってなんとか12準決も
勝って決勝まで行ったんですけど
決勝戦の結果
ん
感じました
ああああああ
あっ
を超えていただきます
はいという気でえっと店舗代表戦に超実は行っていたんですごめんね階段の動画公平だ
と言ってだったんですけどちょっとまたが勝てると思ってなかったので入賞探そう品で
このプレイマットももらってました
これで僕はひとまずまあ日本平のまず一歩を踏み出したというわけでございますそうぞ
店舗代表戦ってどんなのかというとちょっと説明しますね世界一を決めたい
海外も始まっててそれのその予選が今いろんなとこで行われてそれに出ました
大変が流れ始めにこの3カードゲーム id に登録できた step 1店舗代表
決定戦が今行われています第一期ですね3月いっぱいまで第1期がやっててそれに僕実
はですねあの
土日でてたんでしょ実は土曜日はまあ惜しくも準拠
で負けてダメだったんですけども今日ですよめっちゃ悔しくてほんと正直ずっと頑張っ
てきたんだよね左右行楽しいなって校ともちょっと楽しんでやってて勝てたらいいなと
思ってこう
活ダンス見覚えだして結構一生懸命やってて本当に寝る間も惜しんで朝まで友達と
頑張った時もあったり大会で現前に負けたこともあったりここ
でくるに色々あったそれがようやくちょっとこう開花したような気がしました
まあほんと出ている人たちはみんな世界一を目指してるわけですから2と半端な人が正
少ないわけでバッチ罰ですからねと皆さんの想像してるおっさん
ドローン棲む館危険みたいな感じはないですから
そうだねイメージとで以後みたいな感じで葬儀と介護みたいな空気感も静かな場所で行
結構強い子は僕は最初は怖かったんですけどもう慣れると結構楽しいもんであの静かな
空間で一家にこう空いてる日をついて何かできるかというのを考える
感じです公式大会というのはねごめん話ずれたんですけどもで8店舗だけどトレードお
店の代表を決めていきますで僕は今回無事お店の代表になることができました
俺の店と言っても過言である
ないな10 tour ごめんなさいブロック代表決定戦っていうのが5月から始まり
ますこれで倒壊の代表とか関東の代表九州の代表とかを決めていくわけでございます
ここが次のステップですね
まあ5月からなんですけども step 3リッポン代表決定戦日本代表水リストを
決定しますこれが6月の下旬から7月に行われます日本代表かも5
それを店舗の影響でも満足してるんですけど行けるとこまでいきたいですねしてプヨン
世界大会に出場
これで全世界から水で人が集まって世界一を決める大会でございます
遊行すごいだからの世界で大会とかイタリアとかで大会ってやってるんだから乳業
いきたい入ってるけどほんとねー
すっごい緊張スターコントテラスやばかったからね触れまともいただいて
まあ一汗したところでございますいやーよかった本当によかった
文化ねそのいつも一緒にやってる奴らで行ったんですけどもメーカー皆さんが喜んで
くれてて
まあ楽しんで待って余裕業は動くがすごい楽しんで遊戯王をやってるんですけども
まあやっぱできれば勝ちたいなっていうのもあってな遊びの中にもこう真面目に考える
シーンとかがあってみんなで相談したりどうやったら勝てるかっていうと考えていつも
やってくれてる奴らの支えがあってあの
ほんといつも朝遅くまで一緒にやってくれている仲間たちと
勝ち取った
かつある優勝だと思っておりますカードゲームついたらただのカードゲームで遊びなん
ですけども僕はすごい乳業に夢中になっててまぁ真剣に取り組めているんで何かに一生
懸命になれるものを見つけられたのはすごくうれしいと思っております
いやほんともねー
超したからねえちなみに自慢じゃないけど1回戦以外全部ストレートかつだ
10本代表とかもあっこれでしたから心から良かったと思っております
指の最高
と言いたいところなんですけどもまぁ今いろいろ言われておりますよね遊戯を知らない
とはがいたらごめんなさいなんですけども4月からですね遊戯王のルールが
めちゃくちゃ
変わってしまいます今まで使いちょっとカードが一気に使えなくなるぐらいすごい
ルール変更なんですけどいろんなといろいろ文句言ってますけども僕も猫
結構いた例を受けるべきとかもあったんですけども
なんでもいいですよ遊びでもいい趣味でもいいして仕事でもいいですよ何かに6つに
なれるものがすごいほしそう思ってて僕は youtube にも仏になってるしそれ
にプラスして最近はいう行に物になっておりますなので多分ねルールドと変わろうと
まぁか友情を楽しみたいと思ってるんで
4月からも友情を楽しもうと思っております指をれる変わって言うのやめたい人は辞め
ていいと思う
もし止めギターが一緒に楽しもうという感じでございますこれはでも結紀を作っている
人たちが決めたことなんでもうそれに従うしかないんじゃないでしょうか
グッズってても仕方ないとか重い問い猫が初めてと授業
日本代表の権利を目標に頑張っていこうと思います1まず最初のステップアックリアな
無事お水の中をぜひぶっ倒して俺がナンバー1になった
た話でしたじゃあなぁ
r
ぷっ
ん
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
t